Hát đặc lực về của nấu trường dành vọng mỗi đông hàng ngàn không trăm thăm,
năng bước vào những ngày thì đầu quối,
phát hiện trường chuyển liệu trở thành tâm điểm chủ ý của nghe ha mộ.
Thang loa sự thay đổi nước lượng, hữu hẹt sẽ kiến cuộc đua nữa sau mùa dài,
trên nguyên nọng mọng và họ lượng hình bà sự hiết.
Có tới sau trên tám đựng tuyển đã tiến thành thành lọc lực,
xuất tất bại tại vòng kỷ trọng se Games.
Trong đó, xa còn thân tâm bột phải thay đổi gần như tòa mộ các hự chiế,
nó không muốn bị gọi lại thiết sau.
Epidate ispoch cũng nhăn trong chiều mộ thêm vương rửa mật mời để giả tăng sức mạnh,
hướng tởi cuộc cảnh trành chuyện kép, phải các thế lức hàng đầu.
Có về mình và SBN không đứng ngoại gộ vừa trình được,
thể hiện gió sự cuối tâm trên trên và tổ bôn,
phân dứng sự thay đổi đề bất nờ,
rất đặc lực về hữu hẹt sẽ mang đến trận cầu mắn nhắn và nhiều việc tính.
Lều đội tiền nào sẽ mất phá để tiến tới trên vô định mô đông hành nàn cuộc trọng không hiểu lắm,
cho đặc biệt liên hấp dẫn ở phía trước.